Hey there, Shankar here. Do you feel like you've lost your ability to focus? Do you start a task and then quickly find yourself distracted by something else? We explore the research on attention and how you can begin to reclaim your ability to focus in the latest episode on our new YouTube channel. Go to YouTube.com slash at Hidden Brain or click the link in the show notes for today's episode. Okay, here's today's show. This is Hidden Brain.
嘿，我是尚卡尔。你觉得自己是不是失去了集中注意力的能力？你是不是刚开始做一件事，很快就发现自己被别的东西分心了？在我们全新 YouTube 频道的最新一期节目中，我们探讨了关于注意力的研究，以及你如何开始重新找回集中注意力的能力。请前往 YouTube.com 斜杠 at Hidden Brain，或者点击今天节目shownotes里的链接。好了，今天的节目就是这些。这里是 Hidden Brain。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. When children are very small, their minds are often an open book. They say what they mean. They blurt out things. This can come across as both cruel and charming. The little boy laughs aloud when someone slips on a banana peel and gets hurt.
我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。当孩子们还很小时，他们的心思往往就像一本打开的书。他们心里想什么就说什么。他们会脱口而出一些话。这既可能显得残酷，又可能显得迷人。当有人踩到香蕉皮摔伤时，小男孩会哈哈大笑。
The little girl tells her uncle that his face is ugly. In Hans Christian Anderson's famous folktale, the emperor's new clothes, a child is the only one who speaks truth to power. The king has been taken in by conmen who pretend to clothe him in marvelous robes that are actually non-existent.
小女孩告诉她叔叔，他的脸很难看。在汉斯·克里斯蒂安·安徒生（Hans Christian Anderson）著名的民间故事《皇帝的新衣》中，一个孩子是唯一一个敢对权势说真话的人。国王被骗子迷住了，骗子假装给他穿上华丽的长袍，而这些长袍实际上根本不存在。
The king's courtiers marvel at their majesty's fine garments, even though he is walking around naked. Finally, a small child blurts out what everyone can see, but no one wants to say aloud. The king is a fool. The folk tale has many parallels in real life.
国王的朝臣们对陛下的华丽衣裳赞叹不已，尽管他正光着身子走来走去。最后，一个小孩脱口说出了每个人都看得见、却没有人敢大声说出来的话。国王是个傻瓜。这个民间故事在现实生活中有许多相似之处。
Authoritarian leaders throughout history have surrounded themselves with yes men who tell them their every action is wise and brave. When we listen to stories like the Emperor's new clothes, most of us identify with the child. We think that if we were in that situation, we too would be honest. We too would speak truth to power. Today on the show, we explore the many ways in which we fail to say what we mean and mean what we say.
纵观历史，威权领导人身边总是环绕着唯命是从的崇拜者，他们告诉领导人其每一个举动都是明智而勇敢的。当我们听到像《皇帝的新衣》这样的故事时，我们大多数人都把自己和那个孩子联系在一起。我们认为，如果我们处在那种情况下，我们也会很诚实。我们也会对权势说真话。今天在节目中，我们探讨了我们常常未能做到言行一致、口心不一的种种方式。
It turns out, most of us are. are not the kid in the story. We're the courtiers. The power and the peril of coming clean. This week on Hidden Brain. Get to the point. Don't mince your words. Lay it all on me.
事实证明，我们大多数人其实都不是故事里的那个孩子。我们是朝臣。摊牌的力量与危险。本周的 Hidden Brain。直奔主题。别拐弯抹角。对我全盘托出吧。
We have countless expressions about the value of being direct with others. And yet, as we go through life, we often don't just say what we mean. We hedge. We weave. We dodge. At Harvard University,
关于直接对他人坦诚的价值，我们有无数的表达。然而，在我们度过人生的过程中，我们往往不仅是直接说出我们的想法。我们含糊其词。我们兜圈子。我们闪烁其词。在哈佛大学，
psychologist Stephen Pinker studies language, social relations, and the mind. He has thought deeply about what our evasions and euphemisms might reveal about us. Steve Pinker, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you. Steve, as an eminent member of the Harvard faculty, you are sometimes called upon to help the university president raise money. Tell me what this is like. Do you have to whine and dine potential donors?
心理学家史蒂芬·平克（Steven Pinker）研究语言、社会关系和心智。他深入思考了我们的逃避和委婉语可能向我们揭示了什么。史蒂夫·平克，欢迎来到 Hidden Brain。谢谢。史蒂夫，作为哈佛教员中杰出的一员，你有时会被邀请协助大学校长筹款。告诉我这是一种什么样的体验。你得陪潜在的捐赠者吃喝玩乐吗？
Well, there was one episode that sticks in memory. That was when the president of the university recruited me to have dinner with a, as they say, a high net worth individual. That is a euphemism for Filthy Rich. This was one of the world's highest net worth individuals, as they, as the fundraising office says, or to use another euphemism, the Development Office, says. And I took a train to Manhattan for the event. The goal, of course, was to solicit a very, very, very large donation, or again, another euphemism, a gift to Harvard from this high net worth individual. And it was at
嗯，有一段经历让我记忆犹新。当时大学校长招募我和一个——正如他们所说——高净值个人共进晚餐。这是一个委婉的说法，意思是超级有钱。这是世界上净资产最高的人之一，正如筹款办公室所说，或者用另一个委婉的说法，即发展办公室所说的那样。我为此坐火车去了曼哈顿。当然，目标是从这位高净值个人那里争取到一份非常、非常、非常大的捐赠，或者换个委婉的说法，给哈佛的一笔礼物。当时是在
an expensive, quiet restaurant. We were, me and the university president were seated at a quiet remote table waiting for our partner to join us. We conferred and the president indicated that we would see how the conversation proceeded. We wouldn't bring up the gift, obviously. In fact, I wouldn't bring it up at all. Establish a warm rapport, a mood of conviviality and intimacy. And as we were having this conversation in this dark corner of a rather romantic restaurant.
一家昂贵而安静的餐厅里。我和大学校长坐在一张安静偏僻的桌子旁，等待我们的伙伴加入我们。我们商量了一下，校长表示我们要看看谈话如何进行。显然，我们不会主动提起那笔捐赠。事实上，我根本不会提。我们要建立一种热烈的融洽关系，一种欢快和亲密的氛围。当我们在这个相当浪漫的餐厅的暗角进行这场对话时，
It reminded me of something. Kind of reminded me if when I was single and I was at a hot date because, both parties kind of know what you're there for, or at least what issue is kind of hanging over them. But it would be
它让我想起了某些事。有点像我单身时去进行一次火热的约会，因为双方其实都知道你为什么去那里，或者至少知道什么问题隐约悬在他们头顶。但
gauche, to say the least, to just blur it out, even though both sides know what the evening is ultimately about. So I can imagine that one reason the university president wants you by his side is because the potential donor, this high net worth individual, will feel good about having dinner with a star member of the faculty. So you're not the eye candy, but you're the brain candy? Who's the brain candy? You know, on any date, or many days, there's entertainment.
直截了当说出来，至少可以说是轻率的，尽管双方都知道这个夜晚最终是关于什么的。所以我可以想象，大学校长希望你在他身边的一个原因，是因为这个潜在的捐赠者——这个高净值个人——会因为能和一位明星教员共进晚餐而感觉良好。所以你不是秀色可餐的“颜值担当”，而是“智力担当”？谁是智力担当？你知道，在任何约会中，或者许多约会中，都有娱乐活动。
You go to a concert, you go to a movie. So that's kind of the entertainment. but also it was, I was part of the deal insofar as a lot of tech entrepreneurs are very, very smart people who forwent a career in writing or academia or intellectual activities in order to pursue their goal of founding a successful company. But they're very smart, they're very curious. They kind of miss the banter, the repartee, the intellectual discussion, being close to the cutting edge of ideas. You know, they genuinely are intellectually curious and smart. And forging a connection with a university is a way for them to be a member of a community that they long to be part of.
你去看音乐会，你看电影。所以这算是一种娱乐。但同时这也是，我是这笔交易的一部分，因为许多科技企业家都是非常非常聪明的人，他们为了追求创立一家成功公司的目标，放弃了写作、学术界或知识分子活动的职业生涯。但他们非常聪明，他们充满好奇心。他们有点怀念妙语连珠、机智的对话、知识分子式的讨论，以及接近思想前沿的感觉。你知道，他们真心对知识充满好奇且聪明。与大学建立联系是他们成为自己长期以来渴望加入的社团的一种方式。
And so, you know, what are we to put it crudely? And again, this is exactly what you cannot do. But what that evening was all about was, you know, give us, you know, hundreds of millions of dollars, we'll name something after you, and you'll get to hang out with interesting people. That's the quid pro quo. But when this gentleman sat down,
所以，你知道，粗俗点说，我们到底在干什么？再说一次，这正是你不能做的事。但那天晚上的全部内容就是，你知道，给我们几亿美元，我们在一个东西上冠以你的名字，你就能和有趣的人一起玩。这就是对等交换。但当这位先生坐下时，
the president said, hey, if you give us $150 million, then we'll name the program after you, and you can speak to Pinker and Michael Sandell and other Harvard faculty as often as you want. that would put a kind of paw over the evening. It would be, you know, even though it would have cut out a lot of, you know, time, these are busy individuals, but somehow offering to save that time
校长说，嘿，如果你给我们 1.5 亿美元，那我们就以你的名字给这个项目命名，你可以随时跟平克、迈克尔·桑德尔（Michael Sandell）和其他哈佛教员交流。这会给那个夜晚蒙上一层阴影。这会是，你知道的，尽管这本可以省去很多时间，这些人都是大忙人，但不知为何，主动提出节约这些时间
would be like on a date saying, okay, so are we going to have sex at the end of this or not? Even though, you know, there's a sense of which that would have been a shocking thing to say and a not shocking thing to say at the same time because both parties know it, they kind of know that the other one knows it, but they may not know that the other one knows that they know that the other one knows they know it. Language has to do two things at once. It's a channel of communication.
就像在约会上说：“好了，那我们今晚结束时要不要上床？”尽管你知道，这种说法在某种程度上既令人震惊又不令人震惊，因为双方都知道这一点，他们某种程度上知道对方也知道，但他们可能不知道对方是否知道他们知道对方知道对方知道这一点。语言必须同时做两件事。它是一个沟通渠道。
Bits and bytes are exchanged for particular purposes, sharing information, negotiating agreements. At the same time, it establishes a particular kind of social relationship. Are we just transactional partners, pure quid pro quo? Are we friends? Do we have like a communal, warm, intimate relationship? Is it a relationship of dominance?
为了特定目的，比特和字节被交换，用于分享信息、协商协议。与此同时，它建立了一种特定的社会关系。我们只是交易伙伴，纯粹的等价交换吗？我们是朋友吗？我们有类似社群式的、温暖的、亲密的关系吗？这是一种支配关系吗？
That is, is one person clearly the dominant and the other subordinate? People care a lot about which of those relationships they have. And the way you often cement them is with explicit verbal declarations in the case of a romantic couple, it's like, I love you, and then they reciprocate that I love you. Or it can be nonverbal cues having a nice dinner together. That's often the way a friendship is cemented. In the course of this dinner that you were having with this high-net-worth individual, how did the conversation go?
也就是说，一个人显然是主导者，而另一个人是从属者吗？人们非常关心他们拥有这些关系中的哪一种。而你通常用来巩固这些关系的方式是通过明确的言语宣告——在浪漫伴侣的情况下，就像是“我爱你”，然后他们回报一句“我也爱你”。或者它可以是非语言线索——一起享用一顿美好的晚餐。这通常是巩固友谊的方式。在你和这位高净值个人共进晚餐的过程中，谈话进展得怎么样？
I'm assuming you didn't start by talking about money, or perhaps money didn't come up at all through most of that conversation. Money never came up. It was a lively conversation. is a very smart person, intellectually curious. He talked about the human genome project, the development of the brain, issues facing the university, economics. The actual cold, hard financial transaction was, I think, relegated to the,
我猜你们没有一上来就谈钱，或者说在大部分谈话中可能根本没提到钱。钱从来没被提起过。那是一场生动的对话。他是一个非常聪明、对知识充满好奇的人。他谈到了人类基因组计划、大脑的发育、大学面临的问题、经济学。实际冷酷的金融交易，我想，被 relegat 到了，
my people will call your people stage. And some of that was out of earshot of me being nearly the entertainment, not one of the partners. But the idea, both on a date and... and in a solicitation for funds, is to avoid the impression that the relationship is transactional. The idea is that we are in a relationship of sharing, of warmth, of intimacy, of mutual concern.
“我的人会联系你的人”这个阶段。其中一部分超出了我的听觉范围，因为我纯粹是作为娱乐，而不是合伙人之一。但无论是约会还是……在筹款的请求中，其核心都是要避免给人留下这段关系是交易性质的印象。其核心在于，我们处于一种分享、温暖、亲密、相互关怀的关系中。
And so all the signals have to indicate that. Now, in the case of solicitation of a donation, as of course with sex and romance, there actually often is a genuine relationship together with the actual exchange of favors. But still, it's a lot of emotional capital goes into preventing any impression that this is a transactional relationship. Those do occur, but I suspect that probably the most univocent gifts tend to occur when they are considered to be, you know, as they say a gift. something that is layered on top of a communal relationship. And this is, in the case of the university, the intellectual stimulation and exchange,
所以所有的信号都必须表明这一点。现在，在请求捐赠的情况下，就像在性和浪漫中一样，实际上通常除了实际交换恩惠之外，确实存在着真正的关系。尽管如此，仍需要投入大量的感情资本来防止任何给人留下这是交易关系的印象。这些确实会发生，但我怀疑，最单纯的馈赠往往发生在它们被认为——正如他们所说的那样——是一份礼物的时候。这是叠加在社群关系之上的某种东西。在大学的例子中，这就是智力上的刺激与交流，
together with the prestige of not being merely a capitalist profit maximizer, but also a philanthropist for cultural and educational institutions. Those are the ultimate incentives. So I'm wondering at a dinner like this, and the analogy to sexual courtship is apt, they might come a point in the dinner where in some ways something actually has to be communicated, that this is not just a dinner. So in other words, what happens if the high-net-worth individual says, this was a delightful conversation, I really enjoyed meeting Steve Pinker,
再加上不仅作为一个纯粹的资本主义利润最大化者，而且作为文化和教育机构的慈善家的声望。这些才是最终的激励。所以我想知道在这样的一次晚餐中——与性求爱的类比很贴切——晚餐可能会进行到这样一个时刻，在某些方面，实际上必须传达出某件事：这不仅仅是一顿晚餐。换句话说，如果这位高净值个人说：“这是一次令人愉快的谈话，我真的很喜欢见到史蒂芬·平克，”
and then goes back to, you know, his hedge fund or his tech company to continue to make money and has no interest in Harvard going forward. That would not be a successful dinner. Exactly. And this is where a lot of what informally we call social skills, social acumen, jargon of psychology is sometimes called theory of mind. That is your theory of what's going on in the other person's mind. As you say, you don't let the moment slip. On the other hand, if you make it too overt too early, then it feels like a transactional relationship as opposed to one of mutual generosity. I'm wondering, did the donor come through? Did you get the big gift? I think not as big as had been hoped. So maybe I was not charming enough.
然后又回到，你知道的，他的对冲基金或他的科技公司继续赚钱，对哈佛未来的发展毫无兴趣，那会怎样？那将不是一次成功的晚餐。完全正确。而这正是我们非正式地称之为社交技能、社交敏锐度的地方——在心理学行话中 manchmal 被称为心理理论（theory of mind）。也就是你对另一个人的脑海中正在发生的事情的理论。正如你所说，你不会让这个时刻溜走。另一方面，如果你太早表现得太明显，那么它就会感觉像是一种交易关系，而不是一种相互慷慨的关系。我想知道，这位捐赠者最后出资了吗？你们拿到那笔巨款了吗？我想没有希望的那么大。所以也许我不够迷人。
Also, donors, actually, no, there was a donor. Now that I think of it, the donor did not have the entity named after himself. So there was a donation, but he chose having something named after him at Harvard came second to the various buildings with his own name plastered on them. I want to talk about an example of indirect speech in the political arena. In 2016, then presidential candidate Donald Trump
还有，捐赠者，实际上，不对，确实有一位捐赠者。现在我想起来，这位捐赠者并没有用他自己的名字来命名那个实体。所以确实有一笔捐赠，但他选择在哈佛以他的名字命名某物，排在他自己名字被印满的各种建筑之后。我想谈谈政治领域中言语委婉的一个例子。2016年，当时的总统候选人唐纳德·特朗普
insulted Nikki Haley, who was the governor of South Carolina. Here's how a TV station in South Carolina described the exchange. A Twitter battle tonight between Nikki Haley and Donald Trump, of all people. The Republican presidential frontrunner tweeted this,
侮辱了南卡罗来纳州州长妮基·黑利（Nikki Haley）。南卡罗来纳州的一家电视台是这样描述这场交锋的。今晚，妮基·黑利和唐纳德·特朗普之间爆发了一场推特骂战，居然是他们两个。这位共和党总统竞选领跑者发布了这则
message earlier today, and it said, quote, the people of South Carolina are embarrassed by Nikki Haley. Well, the South Carolina governor responded simply, bless your heart. So Steve, when used by Americans from southern states, does bless your heart mean bless your heart? It does not mean bless your heart. And it was rather clever on her part because he was, obviously they were in a contest for dominance. You know, one way to play it is with in-your-face insults. That's the kind of playground trash talk. Haley, rather than taking the bait and meeting him in the same arena, tries to step above it with the non-sequitur. Bless your heart, it doesn't make sense in context, because that's not what you say to someone
早些时候的消息，其中写道，引述：“南卡罗来纳州人民对妮基·黑利感到尴尬。”嗯，南卡罗来纳州州长只是简单地回应道：“真可怜（bless your heart）。”所以，史蒂夫，当美国南方各州的人使用这句话时，“真可怜”究竟是不是字面上的“祝你心明眼亮/愿上帝保佑你的心”的意思？它根本不是这个意思。这其实是她的一种机智，因为他当时，显然他们正在争夺主导权。你知道，应对这种局面的一种方式是用当面侮辱回击。那是游乐场式的垃圾话。黑利没有吞下诱饵并在同一个竞技场与他过招，而是试图用一个不相干的话题来超越它。“真可怜”，在语境中根本说不通，因为这不是你对一个
who just insulted you. So listeners have to then puzzle, well, geez, she's not just saying things at random. She had a reason to say that. Why did she say that? And to read between the lines, it's this kind of trash talk does not wound me. I consider myself to have a strong enough reputation and I have enough confidence that I can, I believe that I will not be lowered in status because of the content of your insult by not playing that game. It is the case also that I think, especially in the American South, bless your heart, is not just a wish for your continued good health. It could also be, you know, another two or three word phrase that might be unprintable, but is couched in much more diplomatic language.
刚刚侮辱了你的人说的话。因此，听众必须去琢磨：天哪，她可不是随便乱说话的。她这么说是有原因的。她为什么要这么说？言外之意是：这种垃圾话伤害不了我。我认为自己有足够好的名誉，而且我有足够的信心，我相信由于你侮辱的内容，我的身份地位不会降低。通过不玩那种游戏（来展现这一点）。这也是事实，我认为特别是在美国南方，“真可怜”不仅仅是对你身体健康的祝福。它也可能是，你知道的，另外两三个无法印成铅字的短语，只是被包裹在更加外交辞令的语言中。
Indeed. And the language of diplomacy, as with all of our speech that is not meant to be taken literally, and that's a lot of it, there's a lot of interpreting in context. And the way that humans do it is by adhering to a principle of relevance. and of cooperation. That is, the ground rules are the listener thinks to himself or to herself, what did they mean that would explain what they just said? And so any socially competent listener can say, she is signaling, you have not wounded me, I'm not playing that game. I am confident enough that I don't feel the need to reply to that insult. So often, what we say aloud doesn't represent what we're thinking.
确实如此。外交语言和我们所有不打算按字面意思理解的言论一样——这占了很大一部分——在语境中有很多解读。人类这样做的方式是遵循相关性原则
When we come back, the many roles that indirect speech plays in our lives. Also, when to say what we mean, and when this can be a mistake. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Stephen Pinker is a psychologist at Harvard University, who studies the nuances of language and social relations. Steve, if we were to sketch something of a taxonomy of indirect, speech. One of the first on the list might be the lies that we tell in order to protect the
和合作原则。也就是说，基本规则是听众在心里想：他说的话究竟是什么意思，才能解释他刚才说的那番话？因此，任何具有社交能力的听众都可以说：她在发出信号，你并没有伤害我，我才不玩那种游戏呢。我有足够的自信，觉得没有必要去回应那个侮辱。所以通常情况下，我们大声说出来的话并不代表我们心里的想法。稍后回来，隐晦言语在我们生活中扮演的诸多角色。还有，什么时候该有什么说什么，以及这样做什么时候会是个错误。你正在收听的是 Hidden Brain。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是 Hidden Brain。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。史蒂芬·平克是哈佛大学的心理学家，他研究语言和社会关系的细微差别。史蒂夫，如果我们试着为间接
feelings of the people we love. Can you talk about this idea, perhaps with some example, Steve? Sure. Someone shows up in an outfit, you know, they've taken a lot of effort to beautify themselves, and even if you think that it might be in ghastly taste, you might say, oh, that's beautiful, you look great. Or even more fraud, as often as, if someone is an artist, and they show you their object d'Ar, and you have to comment on it. And, you know, there's so many ways for that to go wrong.
言语画出一张分类图。名单上的第一项可能就是我们为了保护所爱之人的感情而说出的谎言。史蒂夫，你能谈谈这个想法吗，也许可以结合一些例子？当然。有人穿着一套衣服出现，你知道，他们为了让自己变美花了很多精力，即便你认为这可能有着糟糕透顶的品味，你可能还是会说：“哦，这太漂亮了，你看起来真棒。”或者更棘手的是，如果有人是个艺术家，他们向你展示他们的艺术品，而你必须对此发表评论。而且，你知道，这件事有太多出错的可能了。
It could be if it's a painting of a red barn, it could be kitsch, if it's too abstract, it could be incomprehensible. So you have to say, you know, beautiful, striking, powerful, strong, even if you may think privately that it's hideous. Again, the goal there, again, let's tie it back to the underlying explanation, is that there is a relationship to be cemented,
如果这是一幅画着红色谷仓的画，它可能会很俗气；如果它太抽象，它可能会让人无法理解。所以你不得不说：你知道的，真漂亮、真引人注目、充满力量、很有张力，即使你私下里可能觉得它丑陋无比。再次强调，那里的目标——让我们把它与潜在的解释联系起来——是为了巩固一种关系，
and each one wishes the best for the other. Neither one is superior to the other. Each would do anything for the other. Those are the fictions that underlie a relationship of friendship. I call them fictions. because they can't always be true, but that's the background assumption that makes friends' friends,
双方都希望对方好。谁也不比谁优越。每个人都会为对方做任何事。这些都是维系友谊关系的虚构前提。我称它们为虚构，
that makes lovers, lovers. What that means is you don't want to say, blurt out anything that would directly contradict that tacit assumption. I'm thinking of how this is also true at the level of international relationships. You know, there is a hierarchy between countries, the countries that are richer and more powerful
因为它们不可能永远都是真的，但这就是让朋友成为朋友、
and their countries that are poorer and weaker. But very often in international settings, when diplomats sit down or the leaders of countries sit down, you know, they're very complimentary to one another. They say nice things about one another. So even though, you know, there is some hierarchy between the countries, everyone agrees that in this public forum, we have to pretend like we are equals
让恋人成为恋人的背景假设。这意味着你不想说出、脱口说出任何会直接违背这个默契假设的话。我在想，这在国际关系层面上也是多么真实。你知道，国家之间存在着等级制度，更富裕、更强大的国家，
or we have to pretend like we deeply care about one another. Can you talk about the idea that this doesn't just happen at the level of interpersonal relationships? It happens at the level of diplomacy and nations? Oh, absolutely. And the perhaps most conspicuous fiction is simply the iconography of the United Nations, where Vanuatu, a tiny island nation in the South Pacific, and China or Russia are, at least in the General Assembly, are treated identically.
以及更贫穷、更弱小的国家。但在许多国际场合，当外交官坐在一起或国家领导人坐在一起时，你知道，他们彼此非常赞赏。他们说彼此的好话。所以尽管，你知道，国家之间存在某种等级制度，但每个人都同意，在这个公开论坛上，我们必须假装我们是平等的，
They have the same size desk and the same size flag and the same privileges. In fact, the word diplomacy, which we sometimes use to refer to our everyday interactions, but technically refers to the relationship between nation states, reminds us that there is a lot in international relations that does not consist of actual brawn or brute force, nor wealth, GDP, but relationships of respect, status, power, dignity, and to make things happen,
或者我们必须假装我们深深地关爱着彼此。你能谈谈这个概念吗：这不仅发生在人际关系层面上？它发生在外交和国家层面上？哦，绝对是的。而也许最显眼的虚构，干脆就是联合国的图腾符号，在那里，瓦努阿图——南太平洋上的一个微小岛国——与中国或俄罗斯，至少在联合国大会上，是被同等对待的。
and to establish stable relationships, There's an awful lot of posturing symbolization that goes into international relations. There's a famous book by Barry O'Neill that shows that every year there are probably 100 acts between countries that are purely symbolic. That is, two leaders have dinner together, or one sends a vice president to the funeral of an ex-head-of-state of the other, or they exchange students or zoo animals, or they attend a ceremony on which they raise a flag or formally apologize. There's an awful lot of just social relationships that go on between heads of state. So in 2011, then-President Barack Obama had a hot mic moment
他们拥有同样大小的桌子、同样大小的国旗和相同的特权。事实上，“外交（diplomacy）”这个词——我们有时用它来指代我们日常的互动，但在技术上指的是主权国家之间的关系——提醒我们，国际关系中有很多内容实际上并不包含真正的肌肉或蛮力，也不是财富、GDP，而是尊重、地位、权力、尊严的关系，为了让事情发生，
where he expressed his sentiments about dealing with the Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin Nathan What happened, Steve? Describe this incident because in some ways it peeled the curtain back on what's actually happening behind all of this diplomacy. Yes, it was a hot mic moment. I discovered it when I clicked on some bait at the bottom of the web page, the ten most embarrassing hot mic moments. And one of them is when Barack Obama confided to Nicolas Sarkozy that, you know, what both of them knew, namely that Bibi Netanyahu was a pain in the neck. I don't think they used that euphemism. Now, that was almost an international incident, even though everyone knew that. There's an old saying from the journalist Michael Kinsley
并建立稳定的关系，国际关系中包含了大量故作姿态的象征手法。巴里·奥尼尔（Barry O'Neill）有一本著名的书，表明国家之间每年大概有一百种纯粹象征性的行为。也就是说，两位领导人共进晚餐，或者一方派遣副总统参加另一方前国家元首的葬礼，或者他们交换学生或动物园动物，或者他们参加升旗或正式道歉的仪式。国家元首之间存在着大量的纯粹社会关系。所以在2011年，当时的总统贝拉克·奥巴马有过一次未关麦的“hot mic”时刻，
that the definition of a gaffe in Washington is when a politician says something that's true. Now, by the way, that has been made, somewhat obsolete by Donald Trump, who has blurted out what in earlier times would have been considered gaffs. That's a whole other story
当时他表达了自己对如何应对以色列总理本杰明·内塔尼亚胡的看法。发生了什么，史蒂夫？描述一下这个事件，因为在某种程度上，它掀开了所有这些外交背后实际发生的事情的幕布。是的，这是一个未关麦的时刻。我是通过点击网页底部的一个诱饵链接时发现它的——“十大最尴尬的未关麦时刻”。其中之一就是贝拉克·奥巴马向尼古拉·萨科齐（Nicolas Sarkozy）吐露了他们俩都知道的事，即：比比·内塔尼亚胡是个让人头疼的家伙。我想他们没有用那个委婉的词。那几乎演变成了一场国际事件，尽管每个人都知道这一点。记者迈克尔·金斯利（Michael Kinsley）有一句老话：
of different rules that he plays by. But the default rules are that leaders of parties within a country, leaders of countries in international relations, have a relationship of mutual admiration and respect.
华盛顿对“失言（gaffe）”的定义是，当一个政客说出了真话。顺便说一句，这一点已经被唐纳德·特朗普在一定程度上变得有些过时了，他脱口而出了一些在早期会被认为是大失言的话。那是他遵循的不同规则的另一个故事，
So in this hot mic moment, Sarkozy apparently told Obama I cannot bear Netanyahu, he's a liar. And Obama says, you're fed up with him, but I have to deal with him every day. And it's the kind of thing that people might talk about it like, you know, dinner parties. But to realize the same thing is happening probably at the level of international relationships is really striking because you hear so little of it when you see the polite diplomacy that happens in these international forums. And the tension is that for agreements to be. negotiated, it helps when two parties consider themselves to be in a communal relationship.
但默认的规则是，一个国家内部的政党领导人、国际关系中的国家领导人，应该保持一种相互钦佩和尊重关系。
That lubricates getting to yes. But the paradox being that, especially at the level of leaders, things that they say in private can then float some norm that characterizes their public relationship. So in interpersonal settings, it can be a tricky balance to communicate what you mean while also trying to hide what you're saying. I want to play you a clip. from the 1989 comedy when Harry met Sally, Harry has complimented Sally's looks a bit too insistently, and she accuses him of coming onto her. All right, all right.
所以在这次未关麦的时刻，萨科齐显然对奥巴马说：“我忍受不了内塔尼亚胡，他是个骗子。”而奥巴马则说：“你受够了他，但我每天都得跟他打交道。”这是人们可能会在晚宴上谈论的那种事情。但意识到同样的事情可能正在国际关系层面上发生，真的是非常震撼，因为当你看到这些国际论坛上发生的彬彬有礼的外交时，你几乎听不到这种声音。而其中的紧张之处在于，为了成功谈判达成协议，如果双方都认为自己处于一种社群关系中，事情就会更容易办成。
Let's just say, just for the sake of argument, that it was a come-on. What do you want me to do about it? I take it back, okay? I take it back. You can't take it back. Why not? Because it's already out there.
这有助于促成“同意”。但其中的悖论在于，特别是在领导人层面上，他们在私下说的话可能会削弱塑造其公开关系的某种规范。因此，在人际交往环境中，要在试图隐藏你所说的话的同时传达你的真实意图，可能是一种微妙的平衡。我想放一段1989年的喜剧电影《当哈利遇到莎莉》中的片段。哈利对莎莉的外貌赞美得有些过于坚持，而莎莉指责他在勾引她。好吧，好吧。
Oh, geez, what are we supposed to do? Call the cops. It's already out there. So, Steve, there's something very interesting here. Once something is out of the box, Sally is saying it can't be put back into the box? In that scene in the movie, they had just met. They're sharing a ride across country. That's why there was some motor noise in that audio clip.
我们假设，仅仅为了论证起见，那就是一次勾引。你想让我为此做点什么？我收回，好吗？我收回。你收回不了。为什么不能？因为话已经说出口了。
And they were not in a romantic or sexual relationship, even though, as with my fundraising dinner, it had to be in the back of their minds. But there's a big difference between something being common knowledge, as Sally put it, out there, and something being known privately by each of them. They're grownups. They're two sexually mature, heterosexual individuals. Each one has to know that the possibility of a sexual relationship has crossed their minds. But each one could think about the other.
哦，天哪，我们该怎么办？报警吗？话已经说出口了。所以，史蒂夫，这里有一个非常有趣的地方。一旦某些话脱口而出，莎莉是在说它就无法再收回了吗？电影里的那一幕，他们才刚认识。他们正搭车横跨整个国家。这就是为什么那个音频剪辑里有一些汽车引擎的噪音。
Well, she doesn't know exactly what's running through my mind. maybe she thinks I'm dense, or she didn't think maybe he thinks I'm naive. However, when it is, as she said, out there, that is when it is said in plain language, then the other person knows that you know. The common knowledge is no longer deniable. Another kind of indirect speech is the humble brag. Describe what this is Steve. Can you think of some examples that you've come by humble bragging in your own life? Oh, yes. I once saw a documentary with an eminent British evolutionary biologist, John Maynard Smith,
他们当时并不是浪漫或性伴侣关系，尽管正如我的筹款晚宴一样，这一定在他们的脑海深处盘旋。但“众所周知”——正如莎莉所说的那样“话已经说出口了”——与每个人私下心里清楚，这两者之间有着巨大的差异。他们是成年人。他们是两个性成熟、异性恋的个体。每个人都必须知道，发生性关系的可能已经掠过他们的脑海。但每个人都可以这样想对方：
would be recognizable to any evolutionary biologist. And the British are champions, at ninjas, at humble bragging. And he was being interviewed and asked him while he went into the field than he did, and he said, well, originally I was interested in physics, but I realized I wasn't smart enough to do physics. Any idiot can do biology.
“嗯，她不知道我脑子里到底在想什么；也许她觉得我很死板，或者他可能觉得我很天真。”然而，当它正如她所说的那样“说出口了”，也就是用明明白白的话语说出来时，另一个人就知道你知道了。这种“众所周知（common knowledge）”不再是可以否认的了。另一种间接言语是“凡尔赛文学”（humblebrag，即低调炫耀）。描述一下这是什么，史蒂夫？你能想到你在自己的生活中遇到过的凡尔赛炫耀的例子吗？哦，是的。我曾经看过一部纪录片，里面有一位杰出的英国演化生物学家约翰·梅纳德·史密斯（John Maynard Smith），
Now, this is a truly brilliant man. He invented the entire field of evolutionary game theory, a powerful idea. And he laughed when he said it. In it, he was doing kind of two things. And this was the genius of the expert Humblebragg. He was not saying that he was so coarse as to have a boast. Like, I'm, you know, I realized that I was a smart person and I could make a contribution to biology because I was so smart. I was smarter than other biologists.
任何演化生物学家都会认出他。英国人是这方面的冠军，是低调炫耀的忍者。他当时正在接受采访，被问到为什么他比实际情况更晚进入这个领域，他说：“嗯，最初我对物理学感兴趣，但我意识到自己不够聪明，做不了物理。任何白痴都能搞生物学。”
But by saying any idiot can do biology, both saying, I don't have to worry about people thinking me that I'm an idiot. If I call myself an idiot or compare myself to idiots, people will know to blow that off. I have the confidence to do that because my status is not in doubt. By my lights, biology is hard. If he's saying any idiot can do biology, and I'm an idiot
现在，这是一个真正才华横溢的人。他发明了整个演化博弈论领域，这是一个强有力的想法。他说这话时笑了。在其中，他其实做了两件事。这也是专家级凡尔赛炫耀的天才之处。他并没有说自己粗俗到直接炫耀。比如：“我，你知道，我意识到我是一个聪明的人，我能够为生物学做出贡献，因为我太聪明了。我比其他生物学家都聪明。”
for the kind of idiot who can do biology, I'm thinking, well, gee, I find biology kind of hard. Does that mean that I am, unlike Sir John Maynard Smith, I am not of the caliber that would find it easy. I find it hard,
但通过说“任何白痴都能搞生物学”，他既表达了“我不必担心别人认为我是个白痴——如果我自称白痴或把自己和白痴作比较，人们就会知道这是在开玩笑”，他又拥有这样做的自信，因为他的地位毫无疑问。在我的理解看来，生物学很难。如果他说任何白痴都能搞生物学，而我是一个能够搞生物学的白痴，我就会想，嗯，天哪，我觉得生物学挺难的。这是否意味着，不像约翰·梅纳德·史密斯爵士那样，我不具备那种觉得它轻而易举的水平？我觉得它很难，
and therefore I'm even lower than him in intelligence than if he were to say it outright. So it works at multiple levels as, in general, wit, charm, tact, social skill, often refer to cases where the desired message comes not from the literal content,
因此，我的智力甚至比他直说还要低。所以它在多个层面上起作用：一般来说，机智、魅力、得体、社交技能，通常指的是这样一些情况：想要的讯息不是来自字面内容，
but from several layers of thinking about what the other person thinks about what you think about what they think. That kind of chess game of thinking several moves ahead, except instead of on the chess board, it's in the brains of two people. There's a related idea that is beautifully captured in the comedy series Curb Your Enthusiasm. Larry David, playing himself has donated money for a wing of a non-profit building, which is named after him.
而是来自关于“对方如何看待你对他们想法的看法”的几层思考。那种棋局式的思考，要超前考虑好几步棋，只不过不是在棋盘上，而是在两个人的大脑中。有一个相关的想法在喜剧系列《抑制热情》（Curb Your Enthusiasm）中得到了精彩的捕捉。拉里·大卫（Larry David）在剧中饰演他自己，他为一个非营利性建筑的一个侧楼捐了款，该侧楼以他的名字命名。
The other wing displays only the inscription donated by Anonymous. At the ribbon-cutting ceremony, Larry is talking to his soon-to-be ex-wife, Cheryl, when he discovers who the anonymous donor is. It's his rival, Ted Danson. He donated the whole wing. Didn't want anybody to know. Well, he told you. So he apparently wanted somebody to know. He told me, okay? Who else did he tell? How do you know he just told you? The point is that he didn't need all the fanfare and didn't need a...
另一侧楼只展示了“匿名捐赠”的铭文。在剪彩仪式上，拉里正在和即将成为他前妻的谢丽尔（Cheryl）交谈，这时他发现了这个匿名捐赠者是谁。是他的竞争对手泰德·丹森（Ted Danson）。他捐了整整一侧楼。不想让任何人知道。好吧，他告诉你了。所以他显然想让某人知道。他告诉我了，好吗？他还告诉了谁？你怎么知道他只告诉你了？重点是他不需要大张旗鼓，不需要……
Fanfare. What fanfare? I don't like the fanfare. You're saying I like fanfare? You can tell a few people. He just doesn't need the whole world to know that he donated all this money. You know what? I didn't need the world to know either. Nobody told me that I could be anonymous and tell people. I would have taken that option. So that's a great line, Steve. Nobody told me I could be anonymous and tell people. Oh, it is brilliant. And it... Because it's... strikes to the heart of a very deep paradox about altruism. Going back to the medieval Jewish philosopher Maimonides, who had a ladder of righteousness where the size of the gift doesn't determine how righteous it is, according to Maimonides. If you do it for the glory,
大张旗鼓。什么大张旗鼓？我才不喜欢大张旗鼓呢。你是说我喜欢大张旗鼓？你可以告诉几个人啊。他只是不需要全世界都知道他捐了这么多钱。你知道吗？我也不需要全世界都知道。没人告诉我我可以保持匿名然后告诉别人。我会选那个选项的。所以这真是一句绝妙的台词，史蒂夫。没人告诉我我可以匿名然后告诉别人。哦，这太绝了。而且它……因为它……直击慈善事业中一个非常深奥的悖论的核心。追溯到中世纪犹太哲学家迈蒙尼德（Maimonides），他有一个义行阶梯：根据迈蒙尼德的说法，礼物的大小并不能决定其行为有多么正义。如果你是为了荣耀、
for the recognition, that's considered less indicative of an underlying trait of charitability or generosity than if you do it anonymously. For the obvious reason that if you do it anonymously, there's no ulterior motive of reputation, nor can you call in the favor and expect some special treatment or quid pro quo. In experiments that I've done in collaboration with some postdocs and grad students, we found that people will actually give more moral credit to someone who gives less money anonymously than more money publicly, which Larry David used to great comic effect.
为了认可而做这件事，比起你匿名去做，这更少能体现出慈善或慷慨的内在特质。原因很简单：如果你匿名去做，就没有为了声誉的不可告人的动机，你也不能在事后索要人情并期望得到什么特殊待遇或等价交换。在我与一些博士后和研究生合作进行的实验中，我们发现，人们实际上会给匿名捐赠较少钱的人，比公开捐赠较多钱的人更多的道德赞誉，拉里·大卫巧妙地将这一点用于喜剧效果。
So in some ways, in that clip from Curb Your Enthusiasm, Ted Danson is trying to have it both ways. He's getting the moral benefit of being seen as an anonymous giver while also telling people that he was the anonymous giver. He's really getting it both ways, and that's what gets Larry so upset. Indeed, yes. It underscores the paradox of reputation in altruism. That ultimately, reputation is a motive for altruism. You want other people to think that you're kind, you're generous, you're beneficent. On the other hand, if other people perceive that that is the motive,
所以在某种程度上，在《抑制热情》的那个片段中，泰德·丹森试图两全其美。他既获得了作为匿名捐赠者被看待的道德好处，同时又告诉人们他就是那个匿名捐赠者。他真的两头都占了，这就是让拉里如此沮丧的原因。确实如此。这强调了慈善事业中声誉的悖论。最终，声誉是行善的一个动机。你希望别人认为你善良、慷慨、乐善好施。另一方面，如果其他人察觉到这就是你的动机，
they give you less credit as a genuinely altruistic person because maybe you're in it for the long-term benefits. Another kind of indirect speech is the innuendo. I want to play you a clip that captures this from the TV show The Sopranos. In this scene, a member of the Soprano mob family accosts an old acquaintance in a store, and pays for his candy bar. Hey, how you doing? Hey.
他们对你作为真正利他主义者的评价就会打折扣，因为也许你这么做是为了长期的利益。另一种间接言语是影射（innuendo）。我想放一段捕捉到这一点的电视剧《黑道家族》（The Sopranos）中的片段。在这个场景中，黑手党索普拉诺家族的一名成员在一家商店里搭讪了一位老熟人，并为他的糖果棒付了钱。嘿，最近怎么样？嘿。
Listen, Danny, we just want you to know how glad we are, a guy like he was on that jury. That mob thing, that junior soprano trial. Not working guy? Life and two kids? Performing a civic duty we should all take part in? We know you do the right thing. So what are you here that's being said and not said, Steve?
听着，丹尼，我们只是想让你知道我们有多高兴，能有像你这样的人在陪审团里。那个黑手党案子，小索普拉诺审判。一个正经打工人？上有老下有小？履行我们所有人都应该参与的公民职责？我们知道你会做正确的事。那么，史蒂夫，这里面究竟说出了什么，又有什么是没说出来的？
Well, that is a excellent example. example of a veiled threat. What's being veiled is if you vote to convict junior soprano, we will harm your family. And it can be effective by striking fear into the heart of the target without literally exposing themselves to the crime of extortion. So what the mobster was doing in that clip from the Sopranos was basically offering something that had plausible deniability. If someone came up and said, said, is this what you really meant, the mobster could say, no, I'm just wishing this old acquaintance well.
嗯，那是一个极好的例子。含蓄的威胁。被掩盖的是：如果你投票判决小索普拉诺有罪，我们就会伤害你的家人。通过在目标心中播下恐惧的种子，它可以在不让自己直接触犯敲诈勒索罪的情况下发挥作用。所以黑手党成员在《黑道家族》那个片段中所做的，基本上是提供了一种具有合理推卸可能性的东西。如果有人走过来问：“这真的是你真正意思吗？”，黑手党成员可以说：“不，我只是祝愿这位老熟人一切顺利。”
Exactly. And the question is, how plausible is the deniability? And crucially, the level of plausibility for the speaker and the hearer have to be different for it to work. So you want to be not so subtle that it'll fly over the head of the hearer, but subtle enough that by higher standards of proof, such as you know, you know, a court of law, it would not meet that higher standard. So if a motorist gets pulled over by a cop, telling the cop, you know, here's $100, let's make
完全正确。问题是，这种推卸可能有多合理？至关重要的是，为了让它起作用，说话者和听者心目中的合理性水平必须是不同的。所以你既不能太含蓄以至于让听者完全一头雾水，又必须足够含蓄，以至于按照更严格的证据标准——比如，你知道的，法庭——它达不到那个更高的标准。因此，如果一个司机被警察拦下，对警察说：“你知道，这里有一百块钱，我们现在就把这事了结了吧，”你知道，这会给你带来麻烦，因为你在贿赂警官。但如果你说：“你知道，我们有没有什么办法能在不用做大量文书工作的情况下把这事解决掉，”这可能会传达出你想表达的信息，但如果碰巧遇到一个正直的警察，你也能留下一条合理的退路。是的，留有足够的余地，使其不至于成为达到“排除合理怀疑”这一证据标准的定罪基础——那是一个非常高的门槛。但在日常对话中，我们不需要那么高的门槛。我们可以去赌一把，觉得：“噢，得了吧，他话里的意思不是很明显吗？”
this go away right now, you know, that could get you in trouble because you're bribing the police officer. But if you say, you know, is there some way we can get this resolved without, you know, having to do a lot of paperwork, that might send the message of what you're trying to say, but give you some plausible deniability if the cop turns out to be an honest cop. Yes, enough deniability that it couldn't be the basis of conviction by the standard of proof beyond a reasonable doubt, which is a very high threshold. But in everyday conversation, we don't need that higher threshold. We can take our chances that, you know, oh, come on, it's pretty obvious what he said.
所以在那种情况下，合理推卸责任——在法庭案件中，是指排除合理怀疑的推卸责任，那是一个高得多的标准。几年前，作家布鲁斯·费勒（Bruce Filer）接到了一家杂志社的任务。他要尝试贿赂纽约市几家热门餐厅的领班（Maître d'），以便能订到一张好桌子。史蒂夫，当他这么做时，他想象会发生什么？所以这项任务让他充满了恐惧。他不断想象某个被激怒的领班愤怒的反驳，比如：“你怎么敢侮辱我”或“你以为这是什么地方”或“你以为凭这个就能进得去吗”。事实证明，他本能地用含蓄的影射而不是直接的言辞表达了贿赂。
So in that case, plausible deniability, in the case of a court case, it's near, it's a deniability beyond a reasonable doubt, a much higher stance. A few years ago, the writer Bruce Filer was given an assignment by a magazine. He was to try and bribe a series of major D's at popular New York City restaurants in order to get a good table. What did he imagine what happened when he did this, Steve? So the assignment filled him with dread. He kept imagining the incensed retorts of some outraged Major D, like, how dare you insult me or what kind of establishment do you think this is or do you think you can get in with that? As it happened, he instinctively couched the bribe in innuendo in direct terms.
他会，而不是说：“如果我给你20块钱，你能马上给我安排座位吗？你能让我插队吗？”他会把20美元的钞票放在余光里，不直视它，看着领班的眼睛说诸如这样的话：“我想知道你们有没有人取消订位，”或者“我希望也许你们能把我们塞进去，”或者“对我和说这是一个非常重要的夜晚。”有趣的是，每次都成功了。尽管我们有种种担忧，曼彻斯特的所有领班都是可以被贿赂的——或者至少在他写这篇文章时是这样的，这就引出了一个问题：他——以及由此推论出的……
He would, instead of saying, if I give you 20 bucks, would you seat me right away? Would you let me jump the cue? He would hold the $20 bill in peripheral vision, not look at it, look at it, look at D in the eye and say something like, I was wondering if you had a cancellation, or I was hoping maybe you could fit us in, or this is a really important night for me. The interesting thing is it worked every time. Despite all our fears, all major Ds in Manhattan are bribable, or at least they were at the time they wrote this article, which leads to the question, what was he, and by extension,
他不会说“如果我给你20块钱，你能马上让我入座吗？能让我插队吗？”，而是会把20美元钞票拿在余光能看见的地方，不盯着它看，而是看着领班的眼睛说，我想知道你们有没有人取消预约，或者我希望你们能帮我们安排一下，或者今晚对我来说非常重要。有趣的是，这每次都管用。尽管我们有种种恐惧，曼哈顿所有的主要领班都是可以收买的，或者至少在他们写这篇文章时是这样的，这就引出了一个问题，他是什么人，进而延伸出
all of us are so afraid of? That is, what would be so terrible if the Major D rebuff the bride? I think the answer is that going back to our different kinds of social relationships, breaching the tacit assumptions
我们所有人到底在害怕什么？也就是说，如果领班拒绝了新娘，会有多糟糕？我认为答案是，回到我们各种不同的社会关系中，打破社会关系的默契假设，
of a social relationship, the common knowledge that cements the relationship, has emotional costs which we experience as embarrassment, awkwardness, if they are accidental, if they're one time, or as disbelief, you know, outrage, shock, if they are intentional or repeated.
也就是维系这种关系的常识，会带来我们体验为尴尬、局促的心理成本（如果它们是偶然的、一次性的），或者体验为不相信、愤怒、震惊（如果它们是故意的或重复发生的）。
In the case of a Major D, you know, Major D, they're dressed in finery. They're wearing a tux or a nice dress, and they carry themselves with the authority that this is their kingdom. they get to seat people when and where they choose. That's part of the dignity of being a matri-D. If you're tendering an outright quid pro-quote bribe, you're kind of treating them like a sales clerk,
以领班为例，你知道的，领班们都盛装打扮。他们穿着燕尾服或漂亮的礼服，并且带着这里是他们王国的权威感。他们可以随时随地选择让人们入座。这是领班尊严的一部分。如果你直接提供赤裸裸的利益交换贿赂，你有点像在对待一个售货员，
like a transactional partner, undermining that aura of authority that they have, and doing it in cases where you don't know whether they will agree, leads to that emotion of, On the part of the speaker, it would be awkwardness. On the part of the recipients of the bribe, it would be outrage, at least in the imagination of the writer. And even in the case where it did succeed, which it did it every time,
就像一个交易伙伴，破坏了他们所拥有的那种权威光环，而且在不知道他们是否会同意的情况下这样做，就会产生这种情绪：对于说话者来说，会是尴尬。对于受贿者来说，则是愤怒，至少在作者的想象中是这样。甚至在它确实成功的情况下，每次都成功了，
it may not have succeeded had he tendered the bribe as a naked quid pro quo. He did do it indirectly, and it worked. You know, it's interesting. We talked earlier about the challenge of sexual courtship in the clip that I played you from, when Harry met Sally, you know, if Harry had shown his hand, but it turns out that Sally was completely not interested, maybe Sally was married already, and maybe Sally has no interest in Harry, that would be a slap in the face. And so it's helpful in those cases to put forward
如果他把贿赂当作赤裸裸的利益交换直接提出来，可能就不会成功。他是间接做到的，而且成功了。你知道，这很有趣。我们之前讨论过《当哈利遇到莎莉》中我放给你的片段里性求爱的挑战，你知道的，如果哈利亮出了底牌，结果莎莉完全不感兴趣，也许莎莉已经结婚了，也许莎莉对哈利毫无兴趣，那将是一个耳光。因此，在这些情况下，提出一个
a very tentative proposal that perhaps the other party can reject also, you know, fairly subtly so that there's no face that's lost, there's no humiliation that is meted out, even as both parties make clear where they stand. Indeed. And in fact, in the studies that I have done, that is one of the motives for using indirect speech, that it avoids the change in relationship from one in which one person has the authority, the superiority of striking down another's offer. That changes the relationship. It then introduces awkwardness if the basis of the relationship had been one of egalitarian. warmth and communal sharing. So you don't want to spoil the relationship with one person kind of holds the prerogative of sexual consent and can blatantly imply that the other is not worthy of it.
非常试探性的提议是有帮助的，也许对方也可以拒绝，而且以相当微妙的方式，这样就不会丢面子，不会施加羞辱，即使双方都明确了各自的立场。确实如此。事实上，在我做过的工作中，这就是使用间接言语的动机之一，它避免了关系从其中一个人拥有权威、可以压制另一个人的提议的优越感中发生改变。这改变了关系。如果关系的基础原本是平等主义的温暖和公共分享，它就会引入尴尬。所以你不想破坏这种关系，因为其中一个人掌握着性同意的特权，并且可以公然暗示另一个人不配得到它。
Obviously, the time comes when there's no choice. We're just having to say no. And what part of no don't you understand? If that stage can be avoided, they can maintain the fiction of a completely platonic friendship or in more dangerous and fraught circumstances, such as a supervisor and an employee or a professor and a student, it would be not just breaching a norm, but breaching a law or a rule,
显然，当没有选择的时候，时刻就会到来。我们不得不说不。你怎么就听不懂不呢？如果能避免那个阶段，他们就可以维持完全柏拉图式友谊的虚构，或者在更危险、更紧张的环境中，比如主管和员工，或教授和学生，这不仅会打破规范，还会打破法律或规则，
and they may not want to go through the trouble of making a court case out of it. Indirect speech can be a useful lubricant greasing the wheels of social interaction. But it's not always what it's called for. When we come back, when it's good to be coy and when it's necessary to be blunt. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Stephen Pinker is a psychologist at Harvard University. He's the author, most recently, of the book When Everyone Knows That Everyone Know That Everyone Know
而且他们可能不想经历把它闹上法庭的麻烦。间接言语可以成为润滑社会互动车轮的有用润滑剂。但这并不总是所需要的。当我们回来时，我们将讨论什么时候适合羞涩，什么时候必须直言不讳。你收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。史蒂芬·平克是哈佛大学的心理学家。他最近出版了一本书，书名是《当每个人都知道每个人都知道每个人都知道》
common knowledge and the mysteries of money, power, and everyday life. Steve, there are many vivid examples of the importance of using direct speech. You talk about the crash of Korean Air 801 in 1997. What happened in that tragedy? This is a case in which the pilot, in a social setting in which there was a clear hierarchy, and he was the authority and the other pilots and technicians had to defer to him. In this case, it was clear to the second and third in command that a disaster was possible, but the plane was losing altitude.
常识以及金钱、权力和日常生活中的谜团。史蒂夫，有很多生动的例子说明了使用直接言语的重要性。你谈到了1997年大韩航空801号航班的坠机事故。那场悲剧中发生了什么？这是一个飞行员的案例，在一个有着清晰等级制度的社会环境中，他是权威，其他飞行员和技术人员必须服从他。在这个案例中，正副机长都很清楚灾难可能会发生，但飞机正在失去高度。
It was on a collision course. But they indicated that there was a problem, but they didn't just blurt it out and say, hey, we're going to crash. Wake up, do something, or let us take over the controls, resulting in tragedy. It's one of cases where for all the socially lubricating benefits of indirectness and innuendo, there are times when it becomes cruel, tragic, unjust to persist in failing to describe something in so many words. So there's a trend out there known as radical honesty, which holds that we should all be saying exactly what's on our minds without any indirection or euphemism. One of the leading proponents of radical honesty is a psychotherapist named Brad Blanton.
它正处于相撞的航线上。但他们只是暗示有问题，却没有直截了当地说，嘿，我们要坠机了。醒醒，做点什么，或者让我们接管控制权，从而导致了悲剧。这是这样的案例之一：尽管间接表达和含沙射影具有所有的社会润滑作用，但有时，如果持续无法用明确的言辞来描述某事，就会变得残酷、悲剧和不公正。因此，有一种被称为激进诚实的潮流，它认为我们都应该毫无间接地、不带委婉语地说出我们心里想的话。激进诚实的领先倡导者之一是一位名叫布拉德·克兰顿的心理治疗师。
Here's how he makes the case for it. So the idea is being able to be happy and be related to people and not be guarded and careful and protected and afraid to being found out. That's a lousy way to live. It's a better way to live out loud, let the chips fall where they may. Have a few hard times now and then, but still they get all cleaned up because everybody tells the truth. That does sound appealing, Steve. Do you think it always works in practice? To put it mildly know
以下是他对此的阐述。所以这个想法是能够快乐并与人建立联系，而不是防备、小心翼翼、受到保护、害怕被发现。那是一种糟糕的生活方式。大声活出自我，顺其自然，是一种更好的生活方式。偶尔经历一些困难时期，但一切都会被清理干净，因为每个人都在说实话。这听起来确实很吸引人，史蒂夫。你认为它在实践中总是行之有效吗？委婉地说，我知道
that it is often a health scape when everyone is honest with everyone else and there are some comedies and science fiction plots that actually play that out for the amusement and sometimes the horror of an audience. But the reason that it doesn't is that this is a world in which there are no social relationships. Everything is transactional.
当每个人对其他所有人都保持诚实时，这往往是一个健康的景观，有些喜剧和科幻小说情节实际上将其演绎出来，以供观众娱乐，有时也感到恐怖。但它之所以行不通，是因为这是一个没有社会关系的世界。一切都是交易性的，
no warmth, there's no friendship, because all of us constantly have compromising thoughts about even our closest friends. Oh, that was a stupid comment. But blurting those things out just corrods the tacit assumptions that make a friendship or a romantic relationship or even a stable relationship of respect of a supervisor and a supervisee stable and sustainable. If every thought was blurted out, then there would be no long-term, stable relationships of cooperation. You cite a French essayist and philosopher from the 17th century who wrote about what would happen if we were all open books. What does Blaise Pascal say? He said that if everyone said what was on their minds, there would not be four friends in the world.
没有温暖，没有友谊，因为我们所有人对即使最亲密的朋友也经常会有妥协的想法。哦，那是个愚蠢的评论。但脱口而出这些事情只会侵蚀维系友谊、浪漫关系、甚至是主管与下属之间尊重的稳定和可持续关系的默契假设。如果每个想法都脱口而出，那么就不会有长期、稳定的合作关系。你引用了一位17世纪的法国散文家兼哲学家的话，他写过如果我们都是透明的书会发生什么。布莱兹·帕斯卡是怎么说的？他说，如果每个人都说出自己心里想的话，世界上就不会有四个朋友。
and indeed, if there was a hidden microphone in my dining room, in the kind of unbuttoned conversations that I have with my wife, my family, my close friends, and that was published tomorrow in New York Times, I would be in deep trouble, even though I don't really have anything to be ashamed of, I haven't committed to a murder or haven't broken any laws, but just the unguarded, honest comments that you make about other people, if voiced would negate the assumption of infinite mutual respect and generosity that are the basis of friendships
确实，如果我的餐厅里藏着一个麦克风，在我与妻子、家人、密友进行的这种无拘无束的对话中，并且明天发表在《纽约时报》上，我就会陷入深深的麻烦，尽管我真的没什么好羞耻的，我没有犯谋杀罪也没有违反任何法律，但只是你对其他人说出的那些毫无防备的诚实评论，如果说出来，就会否定无限相互尊重和慷慨的假设，而这些假设是友谊的基础
and of other relationships, relationships of decorum and cooperation. My favorite example, I don't know if you have a clip from this, was in the romantic comedy movie Tootsie, where in a scene in which the disguised Dustin Hoffman, portraying an actress, becomes intimate with a fellow actress on a soap opera, played by Jessica Lang, and she confesses to the disguised Dustin Hoffman. You want to wish just once?
以及其他关系，即礼仪和合作关系。我最喜欢的例子，我不知道你是否有这个片段，是在浪漫喜剧电影《窈窕淑男》中，在一个场景中，乔装打扮的达斯汀·霍夫曼饰演一名女演员，与肥皂剧中的另一位女演员（由杰西卡·兰格饰演）变得亲密，她向乔装打扮的达斯汀·霍夫曼坦白。你难道不想哪怕一次……
What? That a guy could be honest enough just to walk right up to me and say, hey, listen, you know, I'm confused about this, too. I could lay a big line on you. We could do a lot of role-playing. But the simple truth is, I find you very interesting. and I'd really like to make love with you. And then in a clever twist of fate, later in the movie,
什么？一个男人能诚实到直接走到我面前说，嘿，听着，你知道，我对这件事也很困惑。我可以对你撒个大谎。我们可以做很多角色扮演。但简单的真相是，我发现你非常有趣。我真的很想和你做爱。然后在命运的一个聪明的转折中，在电影的后面，
an undisguised and unrecognized Dustin Hoffman does meet Jessica Lang at a cocktail party, goes up to her and says, I could lay a big line on you, and we could do a lot of role-playing. But the simple truth is, is that I find you very interesting. And I'd really like to make love to you.
一个没有伪装且未被认出的达斯汀·霍夫曼在鸡尾酒会上遇到了杰西卡·兰格，走到她面前说，我可以对你撒个大谎，我们可以做很多角色扮演。但简单的真相是，我发现你非常有趣。我真的很想和你做爱。
You know? It's a sister. And of course, she throws him a glass of wine in his face, showing our hypocrisy about our hypocrisy. Namely, we long for honesty, candor, not role-playing and beating around the bush and just saying what we mean. But really, we would not tolerate it. So you've thought deeply about the costs and the benefits of indirect speech. I understand your wife recently challenged you to act on your own theories, and she took a leaf out of that story you told me about the magazine writer
你知道吗？是个姐妹。当然，她把一杯酒泼在他脸上，展示了我们对自身虚伪的虚伪。也就是说，我们渴望诚实、坦率，而不是角色扮演和旁敲侧击，只是说出我们的意思。但实际上，我们无法容忍它。所以你深入思考了间接言语的成本和好处。据我所知，你妻子最近挑战你按照你自己的理论行事，她从你讲的那个关于杂志作家的故事中得到了启发，
who managed to score great restaurant tables with a $50 bribe. But what was the challenge she laid down on the table, Steve? So we were having a lovely stroll in the Brooklyn waterfront, late summer night, and there was a river cafe, a lovely restaurant with a gorgeous view of Manhattan. And we hadn't made a reservation. and we're getting hungry. And I had a $50 bill in my pocket, which was a rare occasion.
他通过50美元的小费成功订到了极好的餐厅座位。但是她放在桌子上的挑战是什么呢，史蒂夫？所以我们在布鲁克林海滨散步，那是夏末的夜晚，那里有一家河畔咖啡馆，一家可以看到曼哈顿壮丽景色的可爱餐厅。我们没有预订，而且我们饿了。我口袋里有一张50美元的钞票，这很少见。
And so she's saying, well, look, you've explained how it works. It would be, you know, it would be really good if we could get in there. You're the guy with a theory. Let's see if your theory works. And, you know, like the writer for Gourmet Magazine, I've got to say it was terrifying. I don't know what I was afraid of. but it did require screwing up a lot of gumption. But I did, and I said, you know, if I have the courage of my convictions, I got to do it.
所以她说，好吧，看，你已经解释了它是如何运作的。如果能进去，那会真的很棒。你是有理论的人。让我们看看你的理论是否管用。而且，你知道，就像《美食》杂志的作家一样，我必须说这太可怕了。我不知道我在害怕什么，但这确实需要鼓起很多勇气。但我照做了，我想，你知道，如果我有坚定的信念，我就必须这样做。
And so I went in, but I was defeated by the site that greeted me at the hostess station. There were two matrikes, two elegantly attired, attractive women, both of whom smiled at me, and I realized that any innuendo that I tried with one would be immediately spotted by the other. Perhaps that's why they hired Major D's in Paris. One of the revelations of this article in Gourmet magazine is that bribing matrives is eminently possible. Now, of course, restaurants,
所以我进去了，但我被女领班台迎接我的景象打败了。那里有两个女领班，两个衣着优雅、有吸引力的女性，她们都对我微笑，我意识到我试图对其中一个进行任何含沙射影的暗示都会立即被另一个发现。也许这就是他们在巴黎雇佣领班的原因。这篇文章在《美食》杂志上的揭露之一就是，贿赂女领班是完全可能的。现在，当然，餐厅，
the owner of the restaurant has an incentive that his or her matrikes not be bribeable because then people would be loath to make reservations if they could just be delayed and delayed and delayed by people jumping the queue with $50 bills. So there's some conflict there between the interests of the major D, which is to accept a little tip on the side, allow their palms to be greased, and the interests of the owner. And I'm wondering whether the owner had a pair of major Ds there just for that reason.
餐厅老板有一种动机，即他的或她的领班不应该被贿赂，因为如果人们可以用50美元的钞票插队，导致其他人被不断推迟，那么人们就不愿意预订了。因此，领班的利益（即接受一点额外的小费，让他们的手受到润滑）与老板的利益之间存在一些冲突。我在想老板是否正是因为这个原因在那里安排了一对领班。
So what happened? You had the $50 bill in your hand and you just put it back in your pocket? What did you do? I skulked away, yes. and we had a long walk to find a restaurant with a table. Stephen Pinker is a psychologist at Harvard University. He is the author of the book, When Everyone Knows That Everyone Knows,
那么发生了什么？你手里拿着50美元的钞票，然后把它放回口袋里了吗？你做了什么？我灰溜溜地走了，是的。我们走了很长一段路才找到一张桌子的餐厅。史蒂芬·平克是哈佛大学的心理学家。他是《当每个人都知道每个人都知道》一书的作者，
Common Knowledge and the Mysteries of Money, Power, and Everyday Life. Steve, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. It's a pleasure. Thanks for having me. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Querell, Ryan Katz, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brains executive editor. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
常识以及金钱、权力和日常生活中的谜团。史蒂夫，非常感谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。这是一种荣幸。谢谢邀请我。《隐藏的大脑》由隐藏大脑传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·保尔、克里斯滕·黄、劳拉·克雷尔、赖安·卡茨、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。再见。本期节目尚无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。